[Musique]
merci Marc Philippe de de nous
accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure élu du NM du groupe les
républicains vice-président de la
commission des lois on va évidemment
revenir sur cette conférence de presse
d'Emmanuel Macron est-ce qu'il a réussi
son rendez-vous avec la nation pour vous
écoutez monsieur Macron est toujours
aussi intelligent mais je pense qu'il
vit dans un rêve il finit par croire à
son rêve
et pendant cette conférence de presse on
avait une sorte de musique envente vous
savez le genre de musique que vous
mettez le soir pour essayer de vous
endormir et et au final il s'esténerver
qu'une fois vous l'avez passé d'ailleurs
quand quand il s'énerve contre le Front
national c'était évidemment orchestré
pour protagoniser à nouveau l'élection
européenne alors qu'une élection
européenne c'est justement une élection
à un tour où on peut exprimer ses
sensibilités donc je pense qu'il a pas
réussi son exercice en terme
d'efficacité parce que le diagnostic est
bien posé tous les problèmes sont là
sauf que les solutions apportées sont
pas la hauteur des problèmes et surtout
quand on se réveille du rêve et qu'on
regarde la réalité local de proximité
vous savez nous on vient de faire des
campagnes sénatoriales moi j'ai j'ai
j'ai fait 300 réunions de dans dans mon
département c'est pas du tout ce que
vous disent les gens sur le terrain et
ils attendent d'autres solutions et
Monsieur Macron il est là depuis 7 ans
donc il dit dit il était avec le même
trip que en 2017 sauf que il y a 7 ans
et les résultats sont pas au rendez-v
vous et il faut des résultats je vous en
parle en connaissance de cause on a une
crise immobilière sans précédent on va
en parler et et le plan borlau soushira
que nous avons fait a permis d'augmenter
de 50 % la construction dans le pays là
on va descendre à la moitié de ce qu'il
faut donc on voit bien qu'il y a
problème il y a un problème de de
distorsion entre le rêve et la réalité
et je pense que de ce point de vue il
n'a pas réussi son exercice il y a eu
beaucoup de mesures qui ont été
annoncées en tout cas une grande partie
du discours a été consacré à la jeunesse
à l'école il a annoncé notamment
l'expérimentation de l'uniforme à
l'école cette année pour une possible
généralisation en 2026 vous soutenez
cette mesure oui je vous l'avais déjà
dit sur cette antenne c'est vrai que
dans cette palette de mesures tousasimut
vous savez il a réuni tous les cabinets
ministériels et puis a demandé des
mesures des mesures des mesures il
ferait un très bon ministre de
l'éducation c'est sûr qu'il ferait pas
les erreurs qu'a commise madame la
nouvelle ministre c'est dommage parce
que elle est bonne comme ministre pour
préparer les Jeux olympiques mais là
elle a mal
monsieur monsieur Macron est un bon
ministre de l'Éducation de Monsieur
hatal c'est vrai fallait fallait pas la
mettre ministre de l'éducation à mil je
pense vous savez j'ai connu ça les les
les tourniqués vous changez de ministère
moi j'ai changé trois fois en une nuit
de ministère sous Sarkozi je pense pas
que c'est pas la bonne solution quand
vous êtes compétent dans un domaine il
faut aller au bout de votre compétence
et c'est la durée qui permet de
d'avancer regarder darana on peut dire
ce qu'on veut avec un contexte difficile
il obtient des résultats sur la durée il
a dit que la ministre avait eu raison
s'excuser pour ses propos maladroit
est-ce que pour vous la page est tournée
bah je pense que c'est ce qu'il a voulu
signifier il a dit maintenant passons
autre chose parce qu'évidemment c'est de
l'événementiel pour vous faut passer à
autre chose elle a été maladroite bah
maintenant il va falloir qu'elle qu'elle
voit l'ensemble des personnel
d'éducation nationale pour expliquer
tout le toute la considération et le
respect qu'elle a pour eux et surtout
expliquer qu'il faut changer le système
c'est pas les enseignants qui posent
problème tout le monde le sait c'est
comme à l'hôpital c'est pas les affirmer
c'est le système qu'il faut changer ce
système n'est pas propice à avoir de
bons résultats le chef de l'État
également parlit de la sécurité de la
lutte contre le trafic de drogue il a
annoncé qu'à partir de cette semaine il
y aurait 10 opérations place net par
semaine pour lutter contre le trafic de
drogue est-ce que ce volontarisme est
suffisant vous savez quand vous discutez
avec les les policiers qui sont
directeurs de zone moi chez moi par
exemple c'est l'ensemble de la région de
France et le port du Havre parce que
c'est par là qui arrive la drogue ils
vous disent que en gros on a augmenté
très significativement c'est vrai le
nombre de dé cent de police pour
démanteler les trafic de drogue
notamment dans les quartiers avec une
pente comme ça sauf que l'arrivée de la
drogue sur le territoire une pente comme
ça donc on est on est loin de pouvoir
rattraper le gap et il y a il y a des
des moyens sans précédent qu'il faudrait
mettre pour y arriver on a fait la
lopmie vous savez une loi sur 5 ans avec
le ministre de l'intérieur ça va dans le
bon sens mais c'est pas suffisant tous
les professionnels sur le terrain vous
le disent donc il faut aller plus loin
bien sûr sur le travail la beaucoup mis
l'accent aussi sur les classes moyennes
sur le travail qui doit pirer sur payer
sur le fait de libéraliser la croissance
semblant annoncer une loi Macron 2 hein
pour libérer ceux qui innovent c'est ce
qu'il a dit la droite aurait pu écrire
cette partie du discours bah écoutez la
droite elle avait démarré un certain
nombre de choses avec Nicolas Sarkozi
travailler plus pour gagner plus il y
revient d'ailleurs mais sur la première
heure derrière bon et et la droite j'en
sais quelque chose j'avais proposé cette
mesure au président Sarkozy avant
malheureusement qu'il soit battu par
François Hollande avait prévu de faire
une baisse de charg et pour les
entrepreneurs pour embaucher plus et
pour les salariés pour pour leur
permettre d'avoir une fiche de paye
c'est pas en augmentant le SMIC qu'on va
y arriver parce que ça va produire des
effets en chaîne et de l'inflation qui
qui vont obérer le pouvoir d'achat des
ménages mais par contre c'est en
baissant les charges patronnales et
salariales et donc il faut un plan
adapté à ça Sarkozy l'avait prévu
j'attends de voir la loi Macron 2 mais
sur le principe c'est plutôt oui vous
attendez de voir les détails mais tout
objectif atteindre bien sûr mais vous
savez moi dans toutes les mesures qui
ont été annoncées hier s'il vient au
Parlement mais je sais qu'il veut pas
forcément venir au Parlement monsieur
Macron il va avoir du souci à se faire
parce que on a on a un contreplan nous
on a d'autres mesures à proposer la
mesure principale Gérard Larchet comme
d'habitude a parlé d'or hier dans ses
vœux c'est de redonner le pouvoir d'agir
aux élus locaux pourquoi la France ne va
pas pourquoi tout ce que raconte le
président peut pas marcher au bout de 7
ans qu'il est au pouvoir parce que le
circuit direct qui permet à un
gouvernement d'insuffler des mesures sur
le terrain ne marche plus parce qu'on a
rajouté des normes des des stradet des
scottes des PLU des sigles en tout genre
des Agen en tout genre et qu'en plus on
on n pas la puissance de feu en terme de
de financement parce qu'il y a trop de
superposition donc la vraie réforme
c'est la réforme Larché qui est prête
puisque il l'a travaillé d'ailleurs de
manière très consensuelle le président
l'archet sur le le moyen de redonner le
pouvoir d'agir aux élus loc justement un
mot sur la décentralisation parce que le
président a dit qu'il fallait tailler
dans le vif des doublons administratif
et Don le millefeuille est-ce qu'il faut
supprimer des échelons écoutez c'est
c'est un des sujets Nicolas Sarkozi
avait proposé le conseiller territorial
on fusionne à la fois conseiller
départemental et régional mais on garde
la possibilité d'agir de manière à la
carte si vous voulez ça ça lui a pas
porté chance au Sénat Nicolas oui oui
mais les régions stratèg les régions
stratèges et les départements dans la
proximité en partenariat avec les élus
locaux la loi l'arché je l'appelle comme
ça qui est prête et qui qui va au-delà
de la majorité sénatoriale elle est tout
à fait adaptée y compris sur le plan
constitutionnel à ce qu'il faut faire si
Monsieur Macron veut une réforme
constitutionnelle et veut que le Sénat
la regarde avec bienveillance le
préalable c'est de mettre cette loi
Larché dans la Constitution un dernier
mot sur la question de la santé parce
qu'il en a également beaucoup parlé
c'est un sujet évidemment qui préoccupe
les français il s'est dit notamment
favorable le président au doublement des
franchises médicales il dit faut
responsabiliser le patient il a raison
bah le problème c'est que euh les
franchises médicales ça ça tape
indifféremment toutes les catégories de
population c'est ce qui reste à charge
j'explique un peu qu quand vous achetez
un médicament quand vous allez c'est un
côté un peu injuste si vous voulez euh
puisque des personnes qui ont largement
les moyens de payer leur leur traitement
médical vont payer la même chose que des
personnes qui sont en grande difficulté
et puis se rajoute à ça vous le savez
bien le problème de l'aide médicale
d'État qui est qui est avec des
étrangers en situation irrégulière donc
il faut reprendre l'ensemble du système
évidemment qu'il faut maîtriser les
dépenses de santé mais c'est sans doute
en faisant beaucoup plus de prévention
pour qu'on ait moins de coût des
traitements opérationnels et en
rationalisant le système de médicament
c'est une vraie réforme qui justifiait
j'ai beaucoup d'amitié pour Catherine
Vautrin puisqu'elle était avec moi dans
le P borlot quand on a fait le la
réforme de la cohésion sociale c'est une
femme de qualité mais le travail et la
santé dans le même ministère c'est trop
pas c'est trop gros de mon point de vue
il faut un ministre de plein exercice de
la santé et un ministre de plein
exercice du logement voilà deux sujets
de la vie cootidienne des français il a
également demandé le président la
régularisation de nombre de médecins
étrangers est-ce que vous y êtes
favorable écoutez la situation actuelle
nécessite qu'on qu'on agisse mais et les
médecins sont évidemment des personnes
qui quand ils sont sur le sol français
euh sont des personnes qu'on pourrait
régulariser mais en faire la seule
solution pour résoudre les déserts
médicaux je suis pas du tout persuadé
qu'il faille faire comme ça il faut pour
autant faut pas atteindre à la liberté
d'installation vous avez une très belle
loi qui a été voté au Sénat à
l'initiative de la majorité sénatoriale
qui répond au problème mieux que la
régularisation des médecins étrangers
allez justement on va parler du Sénat la
semaine prochaine sera examiné un texte
sur le renforcement de la lutte
antiterroriste et les mesures de suivi
des condamnés pour terrorisme vous
présentez aujourd'hui votre rapport en
commission des lois on va en parler avec
notre journaliste parlementaire Steve
[Musique]
Jourdin bonjour bonjouran bonjour
monsieur le sénateur bonjour et Steve la
semaine prochaine le Sénat se P donc sur
une proposition de loi qui vise à
renforcer notre arsenal antiterroriste
oui l'attentat de Paris du mois de
décembre est passé par là vous vous en
souvenez ce jeune homme de 26 ans qui
avait attaqué au couteau et au marteau
des passants à proximité de la tour eel
l'assaillant était un Iranien naturalisé
français connu des services de police et
déjà condamné pour un projet d'attentat
terroriste en réaction certains
responsables politiques avaient demandé
des mesures pour et bien qu'à l'avenir
on puisse laisser certains individus
dangereux en prison même après qu'ils
aient purgé la peine depuis l'été leur
peine pardon depuis l'été 2018
486 détenus islamistes ont été libérés
parmi eux près de la moitié serait
encore radicalisé Orian et le Sénat
demande donc un meilleur suivi de ces
individus oui aujourd'hui les
terroristes qui sortent de prison et qui
sont considérés comme dangereux peuvent
déjà faire l'objet d'un suivi spécifique
c'est ce qu'on appelle des mesures de
sûreté elles sont prévues par une loi
adoptée en 2021 plusieurs obligations
peuvent être imposées comme le devoir de
pointer au commissariat la nécessité
d'obtenir l'autorisation d'un juge pour
changer de résidence ou encore
l'obligation de porter un BRC bracelet
électronique pas suffisant pour les
sénateurs qui demandent de muscler le
dispositif à l'approche des Joos le
texte examiné la semaine prochaine
prévoit notamment la création de deux
nouvelles mesures de sûreté la rétention
pour les condamnés encore engagés dans
une idéologie radicale ou encore la
rétention en raison de troubles
psychiatriques grave autre volet
moderniser notre arsenal pénal oui pour
l'adapter au nouveau mode opératoire des
terroristes il s'agit de s'attaquer à ce
qu'on appelle les loups solitaires ceux
qui se radicalisent seul sur les réseaux
sociaux les sénateurs demandent le
retour du délit de recel d'apologie du
terrorisme qui avait été sens assuré par
le Conseil constitutionnel ça consiste
dans le fait de de détenir des fichiers
contenant des appels au passage à l'acte
autre demande des sénateurs la
possibilité de prononcer des peines de
bannissement numérique pour ceux qui
appellent à la haine sur les réseaux ou
encore la création d'une peine
d'interdiction de paraître dans les
transports en commun monsieur le
sénateur alors il y a beaucoup de
mesures est-ce qu'on peut peut-être
s'arrêter sur cette histoire de recel
d'apologie du terrorisme en quoi ça va
consister est-ce que si je télécharge
des images sur internet de de
terroristes qui sile qui revendique un
attentat je peux être sanctionné bon
d'une part c'est une loi très importante
c'est la raison pour laquelle le
président retaillot et le président
Marseille c'est une loi qui a été déposé
codéposé par les élus LR et centristes
demande un vote solennel qui aura lieu
d'ici la fin du mois et dont je ne doute
pas de qu'il sera positif pourquoi c'est
important parce que euh après les
attentats contre Samuel pati et haras
contre des enseignants et puis le
dernier que vous venez de citer
birakeim la nature du terrorisme a
complètement Chang après Bataclan on on
s'attaquait à des groupes organisés qui
revenaient de daesh de Syrie d'Irak on
s'attaquait à des mineurs qui revenaient
de là de là-bas et qu'il fallait essayer
de de rééduquer si j'ose dire et et tout
ça était plus très organisé et là
maintenant vous l'avez prononcé le mot
on s'attaque à des loups solitaires qui
font des attentats à l'arme blanche non
plus avec des
kalalashnikov avec des avec des
difficultés à l'airpé j'ai auditionné
deux responsables aux responsables des
services secrets qui me le disent de
manière très nette et qui disent qu'ils
n'ont pas les outils aujourd'hui à à
quelques mois des Jeux Olympiques ça
fait plusieurs mois moi je suis vous
savez je suis toutes ces lois euh depuis
le début sur le terrorisme sur la
reconnaissance Faale ça fait plusieurs
mois que je tire la sonnette d'alarme
avec d'autres et le président François
Noël buffet pour dire attention nous ne
sommes pas assez outillés si nous avons
des attentats nous portons des
responsabilités donc il faut euh
effectivement alors le délit de Rosselle
d'apologie du terrorisme il a il a fait
choublanc pourquoi les sénateurs avaient
proposé une proposition de loi qui était
du temps où Monsieur Macron avait la
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale qui
était me semble-t-il mieux outillé pour
passer à la censure du Conseil
constitutionnel madame Bron privé à
l'époque président de la commission des
lois n'en a pas voulu elle a imposé sa
loi qui a été censurée au Conseil
constitutionnel donc le problème c'est
de caractériser la dangerosité de ces
individus et donc j'ai revu la loi pour
qu' vous savez je suis sur un chemin de
crê c'est-à-dire je je veux obtenir les
objectifs que vous avez cité à juste
titre mais il faut essayer qu'il ne soit
pas censuré par le Conseil
constitutionnel en tout cas que le
Conseil constitutionnel tienne compte de
ce nouveau contexte pour prendre ses
décisions de
proportionnalité de la mesure donc j'ai
essayé de faire je donne l'exemple de
birakeim si on avait perquisitionné le
matin de l'attentat chez cette personne
qui a tué
malheureusement un étranger sur notre
notre sol
on aurait pas pu il y avait des tractes
il y avait à peu près 500 tractes
d'apologie du djihad et de la charia on
naurait pas pu le mettre hors d'état de
nuire dans l'état actuel de la loi c'est
quand même
hallucinant même chose sur toute une
série toute une série d'attentats qui
ont concerné
malheureusement Samuel paatti et
l'attentat d'aras on et il y a un autre
sujet qui est les mineurs on a de plus
en plus de 13 16 ans qui sont impliqués
et manipulés de l'extérieur à travers
des raisaux r sociaux et que et qu'il
faut mettre aussi hors d'état de nuire
en respectant leur qualité de mineur
donc vous parliez de proportionnalité
tout ça doit être proportionnel tout ça
c'est c'est la sagesse du Sénat que
d'essayer de trouver cet équilibre
justement comment vous le trouvez parce
que du coup c'est ce sont des peines
après la peine d'une certaine manière
parce que là vous êtes pas
train de malmener un peu l'État de droit
non je malmène pas l'état de droit le
Conseil constitutionnel l'idée de
rétention de sûreté alors quand sont des
détenus avec des troubles psychiatriques
c'est évidemment pas le même
r mais il y a toute une série de
conditions pour que ce soit accepté ça
existe aujourd'hui pour quand il y a
plus plus de 15 ans de réclusion
criminelle alors moi ce que me disent le
procureur antiterroriste que j'ai
auditionné les
juges de de de la liberté les juges pour
les pour les mineurs ils me disent tous
la même chose c'est-à-dire que
aujourd'hui tel que ça a été voté après
il y a 2 ans maintenant on n'arrive pas
à caractériser la la dangerosité de ces
individus donc il faut adapter la loi et
je l'ai adapté dans le sens que
souhaitent les professionnels que sont
les les les parquetiers les juges et et
les services secrets et l'intérieur donc
tout ce que je fais a été quand même
très très travaillé en amont avec le
ministère de l'Intérieur le ministère de
la Justice et les services secrets une
dernière question ouais plus
philosophique plus éthique Jordan
barlella nous dit que il ne croit pas en
la déradicalisation vous y croyez vous
en la déradicalisation des terroristes
alors il faut pas être il faut pas être
en fond de cœur et naïf si vous voulez
mais il y a un certain nombre de détenus
que qui vont sortir de prison qu'on ne
pourra pas déradicaliser vous avez cité
les chiffres on est on estime que il y a
au moins 70 personnes très dangereuses
qui peuvent aller sur les sites des jeux
alors moi je je vais aller plus loin que
je vais enlever le délit le nouveau
délit créé pour ne pour ne pas paraître
dans les transports en commun je vais
faire un déli plus large et qui sera
adapté en terme de proportionnalité avec
des outils que qui peuvent être utilisés
notamment par les par les services
secrets pour les empêcher d'accéder au
sit des Jeux Olympiques puisque on me
refuse à titre exceptionnel la
reconnaissance spciale ce qui est une
hérésie parce que les Anglais ont réussi
à sécuriser leurs jeux olympiques ils me
l'ont dit grâce à ça merci Steve on
suivra votre l'examen de cette
proposition de loi ce sera la semaine
prochaine à tout à l'heure à tout à
l'heure on parlera du nouveau ministre
de l'Éducation de gabrielal Emmanuel
Macron je crois ça c'est ça ça sera dans
le
on va parler du logement vous nous en
avez un petit peu parlé tout à l'heure
c'est l'actualité dans votre région dans
votre département on va à Lille on
retrouve pierre-gérôme montenau
rédacteur en chef à wo qui a une
question à vous poser sur ce sujet
bonjour à tous bonjour Marc Philippe
d'bress une question sur le logement
dans le précédent gouvernement le
logement avait son ministre et son
ministère le dernier à l'occuper était
Patrice vergrit l'ancien maire de
dunerque à l'heure où je vous pose la
question on ne sait pas s'il est
maintenu à son son poste qu'est-ce que
pour vous cela signifie quant au
traitement de cette question du logement
sous ce quinquenin ça signifie que le
gouvernement les gouvernements
successifs de Monsieur Macron n'ont pas
pris la mesure de la de la crise
historique qui qui est en train de se
dénouer se nouer sous nos yeux ça fait 3
ans vous en êtes témoins que je tire la
sonnette d'alarme au Sénat on va
descendre l'année prochaine aux
alentours de 250000 constructions neuves
c'est-à-dire la moitié de ce qu'il faut
vrait faire sous borlau on avait atteint
486000 je le rappelle et et dans tous
les segments le logement social ce qui
du coup pose des problèmes sur
l'hébergement et le logement locatif
intermédiaire l'accession à la propriété
qui est en panne sèche les prês 40 % de
prêt en moins tout crise de l'offre
crise de la demande crise du neu crise
de l'ancien tout va mal les même les
notaires commencent à licencier j'ai
encore vu un président de chambre de
notairire hier là-dessus donc il faut un
plan d'urgence comme on avait fait un
plan de cohésion sociale avec borlot le
logement c'est de la fiscalité du
foncier du financier et un circuit
direct j'y reviens de décentralisation
pourquoi on réussit avec Catherine
Vautrin d'ailleurs le plan borlau et on
le territorialise parce que on évite
tous les circuits compliqués et qu'on
dit on amène tous les financements au
même moment on lasérise l'action sur un
plan à 5 ans et on est efficace à
l'époque on avait consacré j'ai entendu
ce que disait monsieur Macron sur l'an
rue je rappelle que nous on avait mis 43
milliards j'ai entendu parler de 12
milliards c'est-à-dire quatre fois moins
alors on me dit c'est beaucoup d'argent
sauf que ça rapporte aussi beaucoup
d'argent parce que les prévisions
malheureusement pour 2024 c'est
j'entends parler de plein emploi c'est
300000 emplois de mois dans le bâtiment
donc là ça va être très dur il faudra au
moins 3 4 ans il faut évidemment un
ministre du Logement de plein exercice
ou un ministre euh un ministre un super
ministre comme on avait borlau qui a le
logement comme une de ses priorit pour
l'instant dans les
annonces on a ce sera ministre délégué
au mieux sans doute auprès de la
transition écologique ce qui est une
hérésie aussi on veut relancer la
construction les Anglais avaient trouvé
un système de moratoire pendant 3 ans
pour relancer tousimut la attaché à quel
ministère pour vous bah ils vont sans
doute être rattachés à la transition
écologique ce qui n'est pas ce qu'il
faut faire parce que il y a d'autres
mesures à prendre transcologique c'est
gabriheure actuelle non c'est la
planification éc ouais mais à qui à qui
doit être attaché à Christophe Béchu
c'est pour l'instant dans le précédent
gouvernement c'était Christophe Béchu
moi je pense que c'est pas ça qu'il faut
faire il aurait fallu voez un ministère
du du travail et de la cohésion sociale
et du Logement ça Catherine Varin aurait
pu porter ça et et et non pas le mettre
sous sous contrainte écologique certes
dans le l'ancien il faut lutter contre
les passoirs thermiques mais en
l'occurrence il faut faire un moratoire
pour relancer la construction dans le
pays sinon nous allons à la catastrophe
il nous reste 2 minutes Mar pH je
voudrais évidemment qu'on parle de votre
parti DLR est-ce que l'entrée de Rachid
hadti au gouvernement ça a été un coup
dur pour l'R bah c'est pas c'est pas une
bonne nouvelle évidemment bon je connais
très bien Rachid j'ai j'ai siégé dans le
même gouvernement qu'elle et j'ai fait
plusieurs missions avec elle auprès de
du président Sarkozi on s' on se connaît
bien moi je pense sa motivation à Rachid
adati elle le dit d'ailleurs c'est la
méie de Paris et et je pense que c'est
une femme de qualité il y a pas de
problème mais je pense que faire un coup
politique dans un gouvernement au moment
où tout va mal en
France sous prétexte de pouvoir prendre
la mairie de Paris c'est pas une bonne
solution alors mais c'était votre
candidate à à la mairie de Paris est-ce
que ça veut dire que les républicains
garderont Rachid hadti qui visiblement
fera une alliance avec les macronistes
ou est-ce que vous présenterez un
candidat contr B c'est les élus
parisiens qui déterminont nous ne sommes
dé centralisateurs dans nos décisions
mais en l'occurrence attention aux
effets boomerang rachidti peut prendre
dans la figure un retour assez fort en
tout cas ça va pas nous déstabiliser
pour les élections européennes on a très
bien fait de désigner François Xavier
bami qui a une ligne très claire
européenne oui au développement de
l'Europe pour tout ce qui est grand
projet Économie non à ce que l'Europe
prenne une supranationalité sur le la
souveraineté qui concerne l'énergie par
exemple ou les lois comme le terrorisme
et et la sécurité ou les flu migratoire
vous avez peut-être entendu Jordan
Bardella le le patron du RN lundi lors C
vux qui appellent les adhérents et les
électeurs les républicains à rejoindre
le rassemblement national que on nous a
on nous a déjà fait le coup hein vous
savez on nous depuis que Monsieur Macron
est élu on annonce la disparition de LR
à chaque à chaque soubressau bon et vous
voyez que ça s'est pas produit en fait
on disait que vous avez fait moins de 5
% à la présidentielle oui on disait
qu'après l'échec il faut bien le dire
parce que Monsieur Macron a réussi à
protagoniser faire un vote utile de
Valérie pcrè on disait ça y est leslr
vont disparaître ils sont pas disparus
on pensait qu'il y aurait de mauvais
résultat aux élections locales il y a
pas eu de mauvais résultat aux élections
locales et la européenne quel est votre
objectif est-ce que vous avez un espace
entre Macron et Bardella oui bien sûr
parce que notre ligne est claire vous
savez Bardella c'est le c'est au niveau
économique une catastrophe pour l'Europe
c'est presque la même chose que que le
frxit des Anglais d'ailleurs madame le
brexit des Anglais Madame Le Pen était à
un moment sur une ligne anti-européenne
totale et puis par par contre l'Europe
supranationale fédéraliste à la Macron
c'est aussi une grosse erreur parce
qu'on perd notre souveraineté par
exemple le prix de l'énergie ou par
exemple les lois en matière de sécurité
de terrorisme ou d'immigration donc la
bonne ligne c'est celle de François
Xavier bami merci Mar Phil d'OB merci
beaucoup merci bonne journée à vous